[Music]
meet fan bing bing a chinese actress and
pop star who started movies like x-men
in may 2018 it was leaked that she tried
to evade paying taxes on an upcoming
movie a month later she disappeared from
the public eye for three months
when she came back she apologized for
her behavior and announced that she had
been fined over 120 million dollars
now whenever she's in public she's
usually glorifying the chinese states
and thanking them for making her quote
calm down and think seriously end quotes
but she's not the only celebrity that's
disappeared after disobeying the chinese
government
october 15 2015 was the last day gwei
ming-hai spoke to any of his friends or
family two days later cctv cameras
outside his home in thailand caught him
leaving with an unknown man and then he
was never heard from again for nearly a
month
on november 6th gwei contacted his wife
and said he was safe but didn't want to
share his location thailand has no
record of gwei ever leaving the country
he was taken from his home by chinese
officers
what had he done to ignore the chinese
states gwei was a prolific author and
publisher who owned shows in causeway
bay books in hong kong he often
published gossip books about chinese
politics and chinese political figures
dangerous topic three months after his
disappearance a video was aired where
gray apparently admitted to illegal
business operations he said he had given
himself up to chinese law enforcement
and was prepared to allow justice to be
served in china
two years after disappearing gwei was
finally released in october 2017 then
just three months later he was taken
again he released another apology and in
2020 he was sentenced to 10 years in
jail for providing intelligence overseas
the scariest part gwei was only one of
five men who vanished in a string of
incidents known as the causeway bay
buck's disappearances
meet vicky zhao she's one of the most
popular movie stars in china is also a
pop singer and has an estimated net
worth of a billion dollars she's been in
some of the biggest chinese box office
hits and is regarded by many as mainland
china's first ever national idol the
problem was her and other chinese
celebrities started letting their fame
get to the head just a little bit too
much they were flaunting their wealth
and lifestyle on social media which went
directly against china's socialist
ideals in other words chinese
celebrities were starting to act a
little bit too much like american
celebrities they were basically blasting
western materialism and individualism
onto the chinese public they were quote
leading young people astray and away
from the ideals of the communist party
and vicki ciao was the poster child for
everything wrong with celebrity culture
in china
so the government launched a new wave of
policies nicknamed xi jinping's common
prosperity campaign and in an instance
every single movie and tv show that
featured vicky chow vanished from the
streaming platforms in china along with
her social media account with over 86
million followers her name was wiped
from the chinese internet
and then the billionaire actress was
never heard from again
this would be the equivalent of the us
government making kim kardashian or
kylie jenner disappear this was back in
august 2021 and the message was clear no
one was too wealthy or too popular for
the chinese governments
today many believe she's under house
arrest whatever the case may be she
seems to have learned her lesson and has
been silent on social media
[Music]
then there's the latest victim peng
shwai the chinese tennis superstar at 35
years old she had been playing tennis
professionally for over 15 years she was
a three-time olympian won 25 tour titles
and ranked first in the world for
women's double tennis in 2014. she was a
chinese media darling proof that china
could compete with the rest of the world
and produce global champions
on november 2nd 2021 peng schwein
uploaded a blog post on weeble a popular
chinese social media sites and less than
a half hour later the post disappeared
and so did peng schwein
her social media went silence people
tried calling or contacting her but
never heard back and no one saw her in
public for weeks
what did she do to deserve such a fates
this is the disturbing disappearance of
china's tennis superstar
[Music]
as business-minded people a lot of us
assume that the obstacle standing in our
way is also business related i just need
to land the right client i just need
this many more sales etc but ask any
real entrepreneur and they'll tell you
that 90 of this game is mental and only
10 of it comes from the tangible things
and yet in society we have fitness
coaches but having a mental coach is
strange and cringy why isn't it socially
acceptable to have a mind coach well
that's where better help comes in better
help is an online platform available
everywhere that allows you to connect
directly with the right therapist for
you from a pool of over 20 000 licensed
professionals better help is not a
crisis line or a self-help service it's
a secure way to get professional therapy
anytime anywhere here's how it works
first you explain what kind of therapy
you're looking for like individual or
couple therapy then you provide your
gender age location and the issues you
want to work on from there you get
matched with your own therapists and you
start talking with them within 48 hours
through phone calls video calls or texts
and boom you're ready to start improving
your life once you've been paired with a
therapist you can contact them anytime
and schedule weekly sessions and if your
first therapist isn't the perfect match
that's okay because better help makes it
free and easy to switch therapists
anytime you want the best part is better
help is way more affordable than
traditional therapy and financial aid is
also available become part of the over 1
million people improving their mental
health on better health by going to
betterhelp.com jake trying to get 10 off
your first month that's
betterhelp.comtrim with the link below
thanks to betterhelp for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
[Music]
peng schwein became a tennis star when
she was really young her first real shot
at fame came in 2014 when she won the
wimbledon women's double title wenmundin
is the tennis but the super bowl is the
football so her win was a pretty big
deal for years she appeared at national
sports events represented china at
tournaments and spent her time keeping
as low of a profile as possible
considering how famous she was in china
that was until november 2nd 2021 when
peng led on to weeble and posted a long
message spilling the details of an
affair she had with a chinese politician
named zhang jae lee jiang jae lee used
to be the senior vice premier of the
chinese state council an extremely
powerful man he retired in 2017 and
according to ping they had an on and off
relationship for over seven years but
that wasn't the most shocking part of
this post peng schwein went on to
describe a meeting she had with jang in
2018 by then the pair had been separated
for a while he invited her to have
dinner with him and his wife and she
agreed but when she arrived zhang
allegedly tried pressuring her to sleep
with him according to peng she did not
consent that afternoon and cried the
whole time end quote
after dinner she said she finally gave
in and agreed to jang's demands peng
wrote that the trauma had left her
feeling like a walking corpse the weibo
post instantly went viral people
screenshotted the message sent it around
to their friends news agencies got
interested but then less than half an
hour after it was posted the whole
message was deleted web searches
mentioning peng jiang or even tennis
were censored on the chinese internet
and people started immediately fearing
for paying safety
[Music]
the weeble post disappeared then so did
peng she didn't communicate on social
media no one could contact her outside
of china she had been wiped off the face
of the earth when journalists ask
chinese spokesman about her they just
answer different versions of i don't
know or it's not my business the private
accounts of people who share pank's
posts were suspended there was an
internet blackout on all things penguin
related and people started getting
seriously worried even famous tennis
players like naomi osaka and serena
williams started posting with the
hashtag where's pangshui all over
western news headlines kept asking the
same question what happened to pengshui
just like so many other chinese
celebrities before her she reappeared
just as suddenly as she disappeared
people started reporting sightings of
peng schwein out in public and chinese
state-run media released photos and
videos of pain going on with her life
proving that she was totally fine
chinese media even tweeted a video of
her eating with her friends and coach in
a restaurant the coach repeated three
times that the next day will be november
21st trying to prove without a doubt
that this video was current and real
pang however didn't say a word during
the whole thing
at one point selfies of pain in her
apartment went viral when people noticed
a picture of winnie the pooh in the
background winning the pooh had been
banned in china for years because people
started comparing xi jinping to him for
some the picture of winning the pooh was
just a coincidence but for others it was
a sign of distress feng shui was
probably still under house arrest and
that these pictures were just a way to
get the international tennis
associations off their back but it
didn't work everyone just got more
worried demanding to see real proof she
was okay so chinese state-run media
shared a suspicious email from peng shui
to the head of the women's tennis
association hello everyone this is peng
shui the allegation of sexual assault is
not true i'm not missing nor am i unsafe
i've just been resting at home and
everything is fine thank you again for
caring about me one of the problems with
this statement is that if you look a
little closely you can see the text
cursor half blinking right here
suggesting that this email was never
sent because you can't edit someone
else's email that they sent you and that
the person who wrote the statement was
also the person who posted it also known
as the chinese state-run media
because none of these efforts assured
people paying was safe china had to go
one step further
china is hosting the 2022 winter
olympics and having a disappearing
athlete on their hands couldn't make for
some trouble a few weeks after her
disappearance members of the
international olympic committee said
that they spoke to paying over video and
that she was fine and resting at home
they didn't release the video or have
any proof of what she said and the
chinese politician zhangjae lee happens
to be good friends with the president of
the international olympic committee
america proceeded to announce a boycott
of the winter games based on chinese
human rights abuses and other countries
quickly followed actual pressure was
melting chyna had to provide some real
proof soon so a few weeks later a
journalist claimed she ran into peng
shui at a skiing event during her
interview peng said she never accused
jang of abuse and that she never
disappeared everything was fine she was
free to go wherever she wanted and she
was definitely not under house arrest
but she made sure to say all this only
after the camera was rolling
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
this was apology her retraction her
making sure that china and the rest of
the world would believe her story ever
since then things seem to have returned
to normal but like all the other
celebrities that disappeared pang has
been lying low ever since as nicolo
machiavelli said it is better to be
feared than to be loved if one cannot be
both and for the chinese governments
this is just a way to keep their
celebrities in a state of fear to remind
them that at any second if they step out
of line if they propagate a culture the
government isn't fond of all their
success all their hard work can be taken
away from them at the click of a mouse
and at the hands of a few men with guns
[Music]
you